what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and let's get
started so today
um I wanted to start by talking about
um Justin and Haley Bieber so recently a
tick tock came out of Selena Gomez
mouthing a song talking about her ex
calling her now as you guys know anyone
that grew up you know I'm 25 or I'm 26 I
forget some days
um I'm 26 so anyone that's like around I
don't know mid 20s early 30s knows then
when we were teenagers Justin and Haley
were like the couple of the century we
loved them
um however they were always like on
again off again and he would kind of go
back and forth between like Selena and
um Haley Bieber and he ended up marrying
Haley Bieber and for a couple years now
I've sort of had it in my head that I
think Haley and Justin aren't gonna work
out and they're gonna get divorced now
maybe this is like saying water is wet
because like most celebrities get
divorced you know what I mean like half
of people get divorced so saying the
most attractive people on the planet
with the most options on the planet
don't stay together I think you know in
a way that's like saying water is wet
the sky is blue however I'm gonna tell
you why I think they're gonna get
divorced so are Justin and Haley Bieber
getting a divorce Tick Tock thinks so
according to this Tick Tock user by
ariela reader there's a rumor going on
that Justin and Haley are allegedly
getting divorced this year around
September 2023. hello it's over I told
my wife
who is this
best friend listen girl Selena Gomez she
chose violence this morning honey
because she literally just broke the
damn internet with this okay so listen a
lot of people are basically saying that
her new single is allegedly about about
Justin Bieber allegedly wanting her back
so listen there's been a lot of rumors
lately that allegedly Justin Bieber has
checked out of the damn marriage and
Haley Bieber's doing everything she can
to to you know ignite the flame to you
know even to allegedly you know go along
with these pregnancy rumors you know she
didn't help by holding her stomach all
the time but [__] if if we're being
honest girl every time I go out to eat
dinner [__] I'm holding my stomach like
I'm about to get bird to uh top lips or
whatever the auto mom what is on topless
uh so I you know no no shame into that
but you know there's just been a lot of
things going on lately that a lot of
people are super confused about and with
this new single of the queen coming out
on Friday and with that audio she used
from Sex in the City which just some
days ago Haley Bieber said that she was
currently watching all sex in the city
for the first time ever now listen girl
you guys know I love the shade I love
the tea I love it all honey okay but
this girl this this is true this is like
too much you know a lot of people like
oh my God you are reaching a girl Selena
Gomez just gave us our permission to
reach honey okay so listen make sure to
hit that follow because there's a lot of
tea coming out and uh girl You're Gonna
Wanna follow for that honey but for real
though Selena Gomez just opened the
floodgates honey and girl I have my life
uh my life jacket on [__] I am swimming
[__] I am not gonna go down like Jack
and Rose honey I will knock over Rose
and get on the damn uh door so be I can
survive [__] because I mean first of
all don't get me starting the Titanic
because Rose and Jack boat did fit on
that damn girl I'm sorry [__] but they
both fit in this damn door Justice for
Jack
Justice for Jack okay so in the past
couple years basically on social media
you know
you know the fans are very very like
passionate so you know there's all these
Jelena you know fans and then there's
all these Haley and Justin fans and
basically you know for years
there's been like subtle jabs back and
forth between Haley and Selena the
reason that I think that Haley and
Justin are gonna get divorced is because
Haley has been so
adamant throughout the years to like
dispel these rumors to go on podcasts
and like talk about the drama and the
reason I think this is a red flag is
because I just think if your marriage is
good you don't care you don't really
care what people are saying and it's
like you know if this woman is going
around really worried about what people
are saying it just seems to be that she
cares more about the attention and the
opinions of the public rather than her
husband
um
now there's a couple a couple other red
flags I saw with Haley
um that I just don't think would equate
to a happy marriage now you have to
understand right Haley has been famous
from a young age and you know she she's
the girl next door America's sweetheart
type look and and same with Selena but
the problem with and you'll notice a lot
of like Disney young Stars especially
women just cannot handle that much
attention at a young age because it's
the equivalent of a guy getting like
unlimited sex at a young age because
attention is to women as to sex is to
men and so when we just get a ton of
attention it just like fuels our ego
um and so when she was younger you know
she she dated Drake
um and I think you know a lot of times
when a girl has dated a guy that's that
exciting it can be a bit difficult for a
woman to go to you know being a wife and
a mother so this is an article from you
know around a decade ago where it says
Drake wasn't kidding when he called
himself a certified Lover Boy the
canadian-born rapper has had several
high profile flings including long time
on-again off-again relationship with
Rihanna and rumored romances with
a-listers like Haley Bieber Julia Fox
Kylie Jenner and JLo you know and you
kind of see the trend with like the
women that he he dated was that they
don't seem to really have a track record
of successful relationships it's the
same thing with the women that have
dated say Leonardo DiCaprio the way
women leave and they they really don't
have the best track record with
successful relationships because what
you'll see is these women will go after
men with status and the thing that comes
with status is you're then rewarded with
attention so when women go for high
status men they then get the attention
that comes with it and I think a lot of
times the women you know go into these
relationships with these guys that
really we don't have anything in common
with
um I'll take you know Kim and Kanye is
another example of a chick that just
bounced from high status man to high
status man to high status man
um you know I think a lot of times women
become in love with the attention that
comes with it and not the actual guy
because the attention is a reward and
the unfortunate thing too is you know
Haley beefing with Selena also you know
imagine you're dating a chick and she's
rewarded with attention every single
time she beefs with your ex-girlfriend
imagine and I I just don't see like her
actions matching her words because I
keep seeing her say she doesn't want
drama
um but yet she keeps going on all these
podcasts you know talking about how she
doesn't want drama and talking about
um you know how people are comparing her
to Selena which which you know is going
to get a lot of eyeballs and I actually
think Haley seems like a nice girl but I
I think she she's almost in the Trap
that like
a lot of modern chicks fall into which
is when you're rewarded with a ton of
attention at a young age it sort of
messes you up
um and especially with the ability to
date the top one two percent of men in
society and another another
um
another thing I noticed about her too
was that her Instagram is mostly
pictures of herself and not her husband
and what what I found is that women that
really are posting a bunch of pictures
by themselves uh typically are are
fishing a little bit or at least seeing
what their other options are because you
guys know like when a chick is obsessed
with her husband you know that's all she
could talk about that's all she wants to
post that's all she wants to show
um but it just doesn't seem like that
when I see pictures of her in her
underwear and you're gonna see on her
Instagram like this is a woman that is
the top one percent man what what more
could you want in a guy you have a world
Superstar he's got status he's got Fame
he's good looking he's handsome and yet
she still needs the attention and
validation of social media
and you you see this with the the bikini
pictures the underwear pictures so you
know my question is if if the top one
percent of men can't get women to act
right it's like the average guy's gonna
ask the question how is he supposed to
get his wife to act right but I'll tell
you the issue with Justin is that a lot
of men aren't like taught how to lead a
relationship and that they can have
standards and before I even when I was
um researching the story I I just gassed
off the bat that that Justin came from a
single mother home where he was more
influenced by his mom because what you
see is that men in these type of
relationships where the women are
leading and I'll tell you why I think
she's leading this relationship
um in a second but
the men that are in relationships where
the women are leading they really just
tend to
um come from single mother home
backgrounds or
um two parent homes but where the mom
clearly wore the pants in the
relationship so
and you can see Justin's mom's influence
even in his music you know one of his
top hit songs was my mama you know my
mama don't like you and she likes
everyone so you know again it's like
he's worried about the opinion of a
woman instead of like being his own man
but men today aren't really taught that
they can make their own decisions
without women being involved because
women are are constantly telling them
that they need to come to their wives
for permission an example I I thought of
was was when I upset Christian Twitter
because I said your husband doesn't need
to get permission from you to make
decisions he doesn't need to ask you the
same way your boss doesn't need to ask
you to make decisions and you know what
I see in this trend of like controlling
women is that um one a lot of times
they're Christian at because in the
Christian church just for whatever
reason
um a lot of times they they really
preach this like Mutual submission where
men should like get their wisdom from
their wives instead of from God and if
you follow if you follow me you know
that I believe the natural order of the
world goes God men women children I
think men should submit to God and women
should submit to men and you saw a
couple of years ago you know Justin
found God and found church and I just
noticed in a lot of those interviews it
seemed to be led by his woman it seemed
to be his wife's idea it seemed to be
his wife that got him into that
um and and genuinely I think that's a
good thing but I think it has to come
from the guy himself and not the woman
leading him and telling him what to do
because I just think that
you know um that really doesn't work
another Trend I see with controlling
women is they tend to get into their
husband's business and this can be
really detrimental for a guy
um because women we just like to take
credit
so you'll see you'll see women
um getting their hands in in their
husband's business you know maybe
they'll make it a little better for a
little while but in the long run it just
tends to cause problems yeah they just
take more and more credit and so Haley
Bieber recently came out and they said
Haley Bieber is heavily involved in her
husband Justin Bieber's business Affairs
while on the path to becoming this power
couple
uh do power couples usually work I don't
know Haley Bieber is heavily involved
when it comes to her husband Justin
Bieber's business Affairs the road
founder 26 recently enjoyed a romantic
date night with the peaches hitmaker not
only focused on her skin care brand but
also rather a large role in the singer's
business and sits in on his meetings
Haley is taking control and is heavily
involved she's part of the meetings and
she's taking a lot for him a source
informed page six an article published
on Sunday she's the voice they're
becoming this power couple she's a big
part of everything he's doing The
Insider further added the Grammy winner
who has denied he is splitting from long
time manager Scooter Braun is currently
worth around 300 million which includes
music sales the star is also the founder
of a clothing brand Drew house so you're
telling me and you know there's more
rumors coming out that he's parting ways
with his manager Scooter so we'll we'll
see what happens but you know it's like
is his wife really the most qualified
person to be
handling his business Affairs a model
you know be one thing if like this is
what she did but and you know this isn't
like to knock on her but it's just to
show a general Trend that I see in
society is that women will get their
hands in women in men's business
and oftentimes take a lot of credit and
run their business into the ground or
make it a lot tougher on them because
they bring the at-home problems to work
um so you know this is just this is all
speculation so you know this is just Why
I think they're going to get divorced
yeah and the last and the last Trend I
see with like women that tend to get
divorced is they don't have kids right
away
um and sometimes I think women like want
the status of being a wife without the
actual performing the duties of a wife
and the way I think of it is Bieber you
know you now have the opportunity to
have a world Superstars children but
she's more worried about managing his
career it seems like but
um again just my speculation so
the the next the next topic is the
update on the Logan uh Paul fight so as
you guys know we've been talking about
Logan and Dylan Dan is on this channel
they have a fight coming up in October
and all week Dylan has just been
tweeting
oh God picture after picture after
picture of Logan Paul's fiance and guys
it has been breaking the internet I want
to know what this man is gonna make off
of his Twitter ad Revenue this month
because it has to be insane there there
is no way this man doesn't make at least
ten thousand dollars just off of the
pictures that he has put up of of
Logan's fiance now Logan has I think
said some of the pictures are fake you
know which some probably are
but I don't know all 75
like that's a lot that's a lot that's a
lot of pictures that that is a lot of
pictures so
you know Logan and Dylan met at the
press conference this week and here is
some footage from the press conference
so yeah if you show up stupid yeah I'm
gonna show up don't worry just like it's
just like Nina showed up to every guy's
house hey man hey it's your birthday
right yeah it is 30th birthday yeah
y'all I got Dylan again oh yeah let me
tell you my friend we don't want
anything to send to the table if you
know what's good for you you don't want
to start to Riot don't start throwing
cakes about down here yeah don't start
throwing cakes about me John and John
John I have no arm I'm not a baseball
player listen no Cake's been chopped
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
you [__] little [__] ass [__] who
doesn't show up to any fights ever I got
a cake of you getting knocked out with
the camel toe happy birthday to you you
[__] [__] boom in on the cake
I want your boyfriend step
and step up take that [__] out on my
brother hooked up with
up with you at least I got rid of this
song You're marrying one
you ain't never been with any girl as
beautiful as my girl my lovely
my super
's apartment cost more than your entire
name
if Dylan thinks a single photo he's
posted has rattled me at all he's a
dumbass imagine being Logan Paul with
hundreds and millions of dollars in the
bank account and out of all the girls he
could have been with
he chose to marry a model who has a
higher body count than Genghis Khan that
is a true definition of a disciple of
the soy a super [__] man a beta male soy
Drinker and when Logan Paul was asked
about his crypto scam why would I take
my Million Dollar Bet why won't you pay
back to people from crypto Zoo I'm
working on
it I'm working on it Dylan meanwhile
Logan Paul goes out and spends 500 000
on a ring for a fiance who has cooked
him what about the innocent people he
scammed it doesn't seem like he's
working on it I just think that Logan
has and now seeing how he's taking this
personal stuff like his mind is not
there what have you heard from them on
their end zone has put a little bit of a
trap on me but there's definitely
trouble in Paradise I'm not gonna lie I
was like gonna praise him because like
you know I'm all about like trans and
like lgbtq and everything so I was gonna
be like oh it's awesome he like has a
fiance that's trans so I thought she was
and then I looked it up and it was a
girl and then I started seeing all the
stuff so I was like oh she's she's
gorgeous though do you feel bad for her
do you think it's like like how do you
think it's affecting her Jake did this
to me I don't know if you remember when
me and him were gonna fight when he was
saying that he was going out my girl he
was saying he [__] her this whole
thing so like it's a double-edged sword
like you can't talk all that [__] and
not be able to take it that's the worst
kind of person wow
foreign
you know men men sort of getting roasted
for for the chicks that they marry you
know it's funny I 10 20 years ago men
didn't really get roasted like that
um for marrying chicks not this bad like
you saw Kanye Mary Kim Kardashian and I
there was a bit of Fallout I remember
but it was it it certainly was not this
oh my gosh do you know what I you know
what I just realized if you want to make
money
women we just always tend to make the
wrong decision so you invest in anything
that like helps us take back bad
decisions like we're fat so you invest
in bbls we post damn near everything for
attention and then we want to take it
back later so if you invest in any like
internet scrubbing
and you know what I mean like internet
scrubbing software I I bet you I bet you
make a lot of money like instead of
instead of like box wine and cat food
and dog food invest in like anything
that makes women's bad decisions
disappear
yeah or makes us look younger forever
Okay so
yeah essentially we're gonna we're gonna
keep seeing this I I thought
I really wish Logan brought some better
roasts so I really was hoping that he
would
that he would roast him a bit better do
you guys think if Logan wins this fight
that they can't roast him anymore
because honestly I don't even think
whoever wins the fight matters because
he's just so far gone right now
but okay yeah that's the updates on the
Logan Paul fight
um the next update we have is ABBA and
preach made another video about fresh
and fit
um why creators are some of the dumbest
people alive so roll the clip I think
creators are some of the dumbest people
on the planet you want to jeopardize
your whole [__] degree you want to
jeopardize your career everything you've
built why so you can be on Tick Tock for
free
are better than you period today's topic
yeah next year this time we're gonna
laugh you [__] a few moments
later the channel has been kicked off
the YouTube Partner program
saving children right
that was great but saving you guys is
better
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah while we're still celebrating
Professor fig and [__] over are we
celebrating Loki I'm celebrating I'm
just doing a little two-step in my room
I drew a little fresher fit sticker on
the floor and I've been dancing on it
just like this oh look at us some high
value man
losing their [__] here's why one I don't
feel bad for fresh and fit and two why I
think they deserve even worse sure
absolutely everyone's like oh how dare
you guys celebrate somebody being D
platform they say that no I celebrate
people having consequences for their
actions that's what I celebrate and I'm
certainly not gonna feel bad for
somebody who tried to get a bunch of
channels removed from the platform with
their own copyright strikes if someone
tries did we all have short-term memory
or these guys knowingly hired a lawyer
just put out all of these strikes on a
bunch of different platforms knowing
they were false knowing they were false
they didn't care they wanted these
channels deleted yep right and what did
they say at the time everybody that was
talking what did they say at the time
they said actions have consequences you
want to talk [__] get hit the haters
tried to cast Over 30 plus YouTube
channels make videos like slander our
name whatever it is now they're mad that
they're get there's consequences actions
bruh y'all are not gonna be able to run
around and drag our name in the mud with
you know falsely without some kind of
recourse bro like that's just not the
way the world Works what we're going to
do is we're gonna go behind the scenes
get the legal paper to do it for us and
then they're gonna hit you guys where it
really hurts your pockets okay you make
a hit piece on us we're gonna hit you
back but legally can you ask why these
clowns tried to take down Abba and
preach with fake dmca strikes
basically uh we have a lot of people
that talk about us on internet and some
of it is slander some of its defamation
and using our content in their videos
and we're like okay cool we've waited
out for a while for you to stop you're
still doing it so you know what cool now
we're gonna take legal action again soon
because obviously you're attacking our
character in our integrity so at that
point hey it's all for a game I wanna I
wanna talk about a couple things
um one it's really interesting how
they're not talking about why fresh and
fit copyright struck them
um it wasn't because people were talking
[__] about them
leftist channels talk [__] about fresh
and fit all the time they never
copyright strike them the reason that
they copyright struck them is because
Abba and preach made 20 hit pieces on
fresh and fit without adding context to
texts that were sent to Myron about a
girl wanting to come on the show Abba
and preached deceptively edited videos
to make it seem like women had to sleep
with Myron to come on the show they
accused him of doing Harvey Weinstein
type [__] it was not about using the
content so right now they're already
misleading you about why they got
copyright Struck it wasn't about freedom
of speech it wasn't about you know I I
had a lot of videos criticizing fresh
and fit pretty pretty early on again
I've been open with it I've been open to
you guys about this that early on their
stuff triggered me I criticized them all
the time never got copyright struck as a
YouTuber it gets tough because there's
no legal action you can take
um when somebody Slanders you or falsely
edits a video to paint a different
narrative
um and I think just early on in their
YouTube career they were trying to
figure it out but you know most
YouTubers kind of come to the same
conclusion where it's like there's
nothing you can really do they can
really say what they want and get away
with it unfortunately especially when
it's multiple countries there's just not
a good way that YouTube has to deal with
this other than you know to publicly
defend themselves and Myron and fresh
came forward with the receipts they came
forward and gave contacts to the text
that this woman had and then none of the
channels came forward and said they were
wrong and admitted that they actually
falsely accused them of
basically making women sleep with him to
get on the show so it's already quite
deceptive the way they're like playing
this story the SEC the second part and
guys I actually didn't even realize how
they do this until I started to get big
on YouTube and Tick Tock and it was like
these guys I didn't even I didn't even
know
um I'd always been like friendly to
started you know making videos and like
editing out what I was saying and I just
I remember when I started to get bigger
and I never really responded to much of
it but the reason I'm commenting on this
is that you know I know what they're
doing here and I just don't think it's
fair oh then the other hypocritical
thing was in the last month they
copyright struck me three times in an
attempt to get my channel taken
um they sent three DNC strikes on
reactions that I did three two three
years ago
um and really you know if they had an
issue with the content I it I I wouldn't
have even cared if I had to take it down
because this was a very low viewed video
from three years ago but you really have
to ask yourself was it about the content
or was it about that they don't like me
and they just wanted to see me go and
that's really what you're seeing that
they're doing with fresh and fit it's
not fair reporting it's not honest and
it's not genuinely concerned for truth
and that's the thing I always try and
that's why I'll admit to you guys when I
get a story wrong or a take wrong in the
long run because I I genuinely think we
need journalists that want to find what
the truth is about the world instead of
spinning a narrative spinning an agenda
making money and I I do think that is
what I do respect about fresh and fit is
he genuinely is in it to provide value
to his audience you know with the
audience that they have they could have
monetized in way more ways than they
have but really like you can just tell
Myron
really wants to offer value to his
audience he really wants to help men and
it's really interesting because they'll
kind of spin his channel is just kicking
off bimbos or whatever but you know they
have a whole they have a very very
impressive community that they've built
of men that are genuinely trying to
improve
and I've seen it firsthand like what
they've built and you know as a content
creator it's not easy to do that and so
it's always the people that are doing
nothing criticizing the people that are
doing something it's the same thing with
Andrew Tate you know he built the war
room right and he he made this place
where men are trying to improve and it's
always the people that aren't offering
anything criticizing the people that are
doing something
um you know and
yeah I just I just don't like the unfair
reporting and I really just don't like
the hypocrisy that I'm seeing and it's
really hypocritical for them to you know
criticize fresh and fit for copyright
striking someone when they copyright
struck me
um on videos I did two three years ago
and when they didn't they they took them
back when they when they didn't fall
right or when I started tweeting about
it but it's just it shows you that they
don't really care about
what's right they just kind of are
trying to spin a narrative um
okay
next we have we have a YouTuber named
fauzi has been arrested by Miami police
on a live stream after he faked a
hostage situation in his hotel room so I
personally have never heard of fauzi I I
don't know who this guy is but
apparently he was one of the world's
biggest YouTubers and actually
um what had got some YouTube Creator
Awards or something on I guess a couple
of years ago he was really big and when
you see YouTubers like this you really
see
um the price that people pay
um for money and fame and I think it's
almost silly to always think that money
and fame is a blessing because sometimes
it can be a bigger curse than a blessing
and a couple of years ago this guy put
on a concert telling people that Drake
was going to be here and he didn't show
up I guess he he like freaked out and
then kind of disappeared for a couple
years well okay so fousey um recently
had a video come out where he he faked
an actual hostage situation so pull the
clip
send the [__] cops
send the cops
there's a gun to my head right now
there's a gun to my head oh man man he
left 24.
oh wow wow
um
you know and we're we're just gonna keep
seeing this trend of people doing stupid
things for clout for money
um you know I I covered that only fans
model that died for clout for money and
I just think we're gonna keep seeing
people taking it further and further and
further you know having bigger and
bigger and bigger pranks you know
having more and more you know clout
activities because in this in this
today's day and age it's really cloud
economics you know
you're rewarded the more clout you get
and what will people do to get there and
it's really unfortunate because I
honestly was watching um a couple of his
live streams he did with snico and he
seems like a funny a funny nice guy but
I just don't know you know
I I just think when you're live
streaming and faking a hostage situation
it it really
yeah I mean that's that's too far that's
that's way too far all right so feminist
campaigners are accusing Prince William
and David Beckham of being openly sexist
for sending messages of support to
England ahead of the World Cup final
both Prince William and David Beckham
sending videos of themselves and their
daughters to the lionesses before their
World Cup 2023 match last night
um was openly sexist so uh Pierce Morgan
actually weighed in on this and he said
he should explain why he can't be there
I mean Pierce this is obvious
nobody wants to watch women's sports and
you know what it's so funny it's so
funny I'm like I'm like Pierce I can
make this I could give you a
play-by-play of why he doesn't want to
be there I swear I'll make this and this
is coming I play basketball in England I
played volleyball in England I had Pro
contracts that I was looking at before
the YouTube thing took off the YouTube
thing took off I was like all right all
right I'll I'll do YouTube instead but
guys you know I'll I'll tell you from
playing volleyball for 16 years I'll
tell you this nobody wants to watch none
of the people virtue signaling about
women's sports and calling it important
were ever in our stance and you know
what I I think I might play a little bit
this year
um on and off and when I'm in England so
I'll give you I'll give you my match
schedule and anybody that wants to come
support in England you know
feel free come to the games all these
virtue signaling all the feminists that
are virtue signaling and criticizing
this man for not wanting to attend
honestly is a stupid game you know we're
not that good at sports
um the men are more entertaining and I
really think we should just be thinking
saying thank you to the men for allowing
us to have a league that they pay for
and they subsidize and stop whining if
the men don't want to come because
honestly I'm a female athlete I don't
even want to watch women's sports and
most women don't even watch women's
sports like if you ask most women
basketball players to name five female
and five male basketball players they'll
always name the male basketball players
first I don't make up the rules guys and
this is coming from someone I would love
nothing more
and to be a female athlete that was what
I wanted to do I I guys I loved Sports
um you're talking to a girl from the
time I was I was 15 years old I think
maybe even younger uh when did I join
travel 14.
I would do travel basketball travel
volleyball
every weekend pretty much every weekend
I spent eight hours in a gym for two
days Saturdays and Sundays
um I would probably travel out of state
twice a month um to go play and I I
would go to school and then I would have
two to three hours of volleyball
practice and basketball practice I also
tried soccer for a season I did track in
college I did basketball and volleyball
in college I love sports like you were
talking to this to the chick spent all
of her time playing sports that always
wanted to learn a new sport and even I
can tell you why they don't want to be
there because we're not that good and
the only time women really get fans like
that is when there's some sort of
community built around it even when we
get a lot of fans we don't usually make
money and I say this I I don't say this
in a happy way but when
NCAA operates at a loss when now the the
unhappy soccer feminists are asking for
more and more money
the truth of the matter is
that women in the words of Myron games
women don't deserve more we deserve less
and instead of whining we should just be
grateful for what we have and I really
think that's the biggest lesson that we
need to learn as women is being content
and grateful because too many times
nowadays we ruin a good thing by
complaining and whining we we ruin a
good marriage by complaining and whining
and leaving we ruin a good League by
complaining and whining and until we as
women learn to stop whining stop
complaining at some point the men are
gonna get fed up and they're just gonna
start cutting our [__] and you know who
I'm gonna blame all these goddamn
feminists that use female sports to
Virtue signal and are going to end up
getting it taken away that's my
prediction I think women's sports will
end because feminists will keep asking
for more and more and more and keep
whining more and more and more and just
get the whole thing taken away that's my
that's my prediction but let me know
what you guys think in the comments um
like the video on your way out and let
me know what topic do you want me to
cover next week tell me what trends you
see like the video subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time